but steve
there's something i need to tell you
what
what's it gonna be called again
lizzo is a hundred percent that snl host
who can't keep it together
sure thank you
in her first time hosting saturday night
live the pop star breaks character more
than once
oh my gosh
this is gonna be a hit starting with
this sketch about the black-eyed peas
i'm on that next ish now i'm so 2008 you
sow 2 000 in late yes that's amazing but
i want it to be 3008.
okay why cause it's bigger
fine do you have any other notes my
house okay thank you fergie
the cast later tackles a bygone trend in
the night's final sketch
i think i've heard that a lot of beanie
babies aren't actually worth that much
god damn it
maybe i start drawing mario full time
what you can't make money drawing mario
steve
last week i drew you a mario you said it
was the best one you'd ever seen
it was while the toys might not be worth
much these days watching lizzo try to
stay in character is priceless
but steve
there's something i need to tell you
what
i shouldn't be drinking that
the reason i'm worried about money is
you're going to be a daddy
oh my god
i'll be a daddy
and there's even more highlights from
studio 8h
i don't know what to say i love my mommy
yep lizzo makes her big night a family
affair enlisting her mother to introduce
her performance of specials
once again my daughter
lizzo you're special
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
even when she's not singing on stage the
show gives lizzo plenty of moments to
bust a move
it's called manifesting
[Applause]
whether it's her trademark flute oh so
you want me to sit down on the twerk
got it
[Applause]
or another nostalgic flashback hey
anyone remember this six flags
commercial well pretend like i'm not
even here
[Applause]
wait
what
we like to party
[Applause]
you